قال مراسيل الجزيره نقرا على مصادر عسكريه
اوكرانيه في اقليم دوباس قال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تخوض معارك ضد القوات الروسيه
في 9 مناطق على الاقل من مقاطعه دوناتسك
واكله المصادر ان القوات الاوكرانيه صدت
كل الهجمات الروسيه في محور مدينه باخموت
الجيش الاوكراني اسقط مروحيه روسيه
وقال الجيش الاوكراني في بيان ان قوته
دمرت ثلاثه مستودعات ذخيره الروسيه في
الاسلام وخيرسون واسقطت سته مسيرات جنوب
البلاد كما استهدفت الياتهم للقوات
الروسيه في المقاطعه واكد الجيش الاوكراني
انه دمرتلا عسكريا روسيا حاول عبور نهر من
غير سؤال
خلصون المواليه لروسيا نحو 700 من سكان
المدينه
ان عمليه الاجلاء التجري بشكل الزامي
وسيتم نقل السكان الى مدينه طوباسي جنوب
روسيا وذلك للحفاظ على حياتهم من خطر اي
هجوم اوكراني المحتمل وضف ان هناك مخاطر
اخرى تهدد حياه المدنيين في حال بقائهم
منها احتماله فيضان نهر اذا قصفت القوته
الاوكرانيه سده
ومن دونالدز في مراسل الجزيره امين درهام
امين ضرغامي حددتنا في نشرتين نشره سابقه
ان القتال والقذف المتبادل ما زال
المتواصله على طول الجبهه وانه هناك حديث
عن استهدافي حيين ثقيلا الاوكرانيه ماذا
في تفاصيل
تحيه طيبه عبد الصمد قبل قليل ايضا للمره
الثالثه اليوم سلطات مدينه دونيات عن
التجدد القصف واصوات وهذا القصف في
الحقيقه لم تتوقف منذ تقريبا الساعه 10:00
من صباح اليوم على عدد من المحاور هنا في
مدينه دمياط تحديدا على
كوبسكي وتروفسكي وايضا قبل قليل اعلن عن
استهداف منطقه سكنيه في حي كيف سكي قبل
ذلك همم اعلن ايضا عن جرح ثلاثه
هذا القصف الذي يبدو انه متبادل بحكم ان
اصوات المدفعيه التابعه لها القوات
المواليه لروسيا ايضا تسمع من هنا من وسط
في ما يبدو انها تستهدف مناطق تمركز
القوات الاوكرانيه في شمال المدينه
وتحديدا في ماده في كما هو الحاله الان
كان في مدينه
افديفكا وايضا في محيط مطار دونياس
كالدولي حيث تدور ال ال المعارك من اجل
السيطره كما تقول القوات المواليه لروسيا
على بلده بيرفوماي سكويا وهي احدى بلدات
الطوق هنا قرب مدينه دنياسكم اذا ما تم
طبعا السيطره على تلك المنطقه تكون القوات
المواليه لروسيا قد وسعت همم مساحه تحركها
في شمال مطار دونيسك بعد ان كانت كما نعلم
قبل شهرين قد سيطرت على بلده بيسكي
المجاوره وبالتالي تكون ايضا قد بدات
بتشكيل طوق حول مدينه ارض الهامه
والاستراتيجيه بالنسبه للجانب الروسي
معارك ايضا شرسه تدور في محيط مدينه باخمه
يقودها طبعا مقاتل شركه فاجنر التي تقاتل
الى جانب القوات الروسيه اما في محور اوبل
فيبدوا ان هناك كر وفر بين الجانبين همم
مره بالسيطره على بلده بارليفكا القريبه
من هذه المدينه وبعد ذلك طبعا
المواليد لروسيا قد اعلن على انه من سحبوا
اا على وقع طبعا همم ما قيل انه همم يعني
مقاومه او انها مقاومه من القوات
الاوكرانيه ايضا يبدو ان الجيش الروسي
يستهدف مخازن لاسلحه كما حدث الليله
الماضيه في مدينه باكروسك التي تبعد عنه
من هنا بنحو 30 كلم
ولم يحدد الجانب الاخر هي الجانب
الاوكراني همم يعني مخالفات هذا القصف او
الحصيله من وراء طبعا هناك ايضا همم على
ما يبدو زياده في حده القذف المدعي في
محور خيرسون كريم
فقال بان هذا القصف الذي تجدد اليوم
المدفع منه وايضا برجمات الصواريخ لم
تشهدوا المنطقه منذ اكثر من اسبوع وهذا
طبعا يتزامن مع تواصل عمليه اجلاء
المدنيين حيث اعلنت سلطات مدينه كخوفقا
المواليه لروسيا على انهم همم تمكنوا من
اجلاء 700 شخص اليوم باتجاه شبه جزيره
القرم
ومن تم الى مدينه توباسيه همم التي تقع في
جنوب روسيا في ما يبدو انه محاولات من قبل
القوات الروسيه في تلك المنطقه تعزيز اولا
الدفاعاتها وثانيا اخلاء المنطقه لتمكين
القوات الروسيه من التحرك وهمم تكثيف
عملياتها العسكريه
شكرا شكرا